اعلنت وزاره داخليه في قطاع غزه وفاه جميع
من كانوا في المبنى السكني الذي اتهمته
النيران في مخيم جباليا شمالي القطاع
وعددهم واحد وعشرون
التحقيقات الاوليه في الحادث اشاره الى
وجود كميات كبيره من البنزين داخل المبنى
من ما اججرا
وزاره الداخليه والامن الوطني انها شكلت
لجنه مختصره للتحقيق في هذا الحادث
والوقوف على كافه ملابساته
وقد تبين من التحقيقات الاوليه
بوجود كميه من ماده البنزين داخل المنزل
المحترق ساهم بتصاعد الحريق بشكل هائل
ووقوع هذا العدد الكبير من حالات الوفاه
دراغون شامل ونعمه قطاع غزه حداد على
ارواح الضحايا بدعوه من القوى الوطنيه
والاسلاميه
تعيد تذكير العالم بالماسات الانسانيه
التي يعيشها قطاع غزه بسبب الحصار وطلب
مسماه العالم الحره خذ ما يلزم في وجه
الاحتلال ومن يتواطئ معه حركه حماس وفي
بيان لها كانت حملت الاحتلال المسؤوليه عن
طريق مخيم جباليا بسبب استمرار الحصار
وقله الامكانات
الشعب الفلسطيني حسب ما جاء في البيان
من مخيم جباليا شماليه قطاع غزه ينضم
الينا مراسل الجزيره والى الدحدوح هل هناك
اي معلومات جديده في ما يتعلق بالتحقيقات
وهل بدات الشيعه
حتى الان التحقيقات ما زالت مستمره للوقوف
على التفاصيل الدقيقه للسبب المباشر
والرئيسي لملابسات هذا الحريق الهائل
والمفجع واا قبل قليل خرج من هنا النائب
العام في قطاع غزه المستشار محمد النحال
وقال بانه اتم هنا الاجراءات وانتقل الى
المكان الذي شهد هذا الحريق اي الى المنزل
الذي التهمته النيران في محاوله لاستكمال
التحقيقات اللازمه عبر الفرق الفنيه
التابعه للنيابه العامه هنا في قطاع غزه
للخروج بعد ذلك
بالملابسات الدقيقه واعلانها للراي العام
لكن السبب الرئيسي المعلن على الاقل حتى
الان هو ان هناك كميات من البنزين كانت
موجوده في المنزل هي التي ساعدت وسرعت في
عمليات الحريق هنا في المستشفى الاندونيسي
همم كما تلاحظون
اخرج تباعا تخرج تباعا عمليا عمليه
التشييع بدات بالفعل من المستشفى
الاندونيسي همم نحو 20 جثه من من الضحايا
الذين سقطوا في الحريق خرجوا بعد عمليه
التكفين
والتوشيح بالعالم الفلسطيني ومن ثم الخروج
تباعا الى مسجد الخلفاء الراشدين همم
الخلفاء الراشدين لاكماء لالقاء لاقامه
الصلاه على الجثامين ومن ثم مباراههم
الثرى في المقبره وهذا حتى الان هو
البرنامج المعروف هنا بطبيعه الحال ذوي
الضحايا الذين اتهمتهم النيران والعشرات
او المئات من المواطنين امام المسجد احتشد
الالاف لهذا الحزن للتعبير عن حزنهم
العميق
مع ذوي الضحايا في واحده من الف القليله
والنادره التي شهدها قطاع غزه على على هذا
النحو ان تتهم النيران منزلا واحدا وتكون
الضحايا بهذا العدد بالتاكيد هذا هذا يعني
كان له وقع كبير